jetzt brechen offenbar alle Dämme die
süd-ukraine droht buchstäblich
unterzugehen in den Wassermassen des
Stausees von kachowka 10.000 Menschen
und viele Tiere sind in extremer Gefahr
Ackerflächen und Infrastruktur ebenso
zivile Ziele eines militärischen
Angriffs also ein Kriegsverbrechen über
die weltweit die Haltung zum
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
verändern wer solidarisiert sich mit
Kiew wer hält sich raus auf wen kann
Putin zählen die Antworten werden
weitreichende Folgen für die
internationale Sicherheit haben
dann Bruch in der Ukraine wie brenzlig
ist die Weltlage jetzt in der Phönix
Runde
Phoenix Runde
Bilder aus der vergangenen Nacht eine
Explosion erschüttert die Staumauer von
novakarovka eine zweite Explosion
zerstört das offenbar in der Nähe
gelegene Wasserkraftwerk
die Karte zeigt welche Risiken Ausmaße
der Stausee im Süden der Ukraine hat
Wasserinhalt
unvorstellbare 18 Milliarden Kubikmeter
ja und damit herzlich Willkommen bei uns
meine Gäste hier im Studio Katrin Krüger
eschbrook sie sind Expertin für
transatlantische Beziehungen der
Bertelsmannstiftung Markus Keime Experte
für Sicherheitspolitik der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik hier in Berlin
August asien-redakteur bei der Deutschen
Welle und zugeschaltet aus Innsbruck ist
Gerd Mangold Professor für
internationale Beziehungen an der
Universität in Innsbruck Liebe
ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer bevor wir
hier loslegen ein kurzes schaltgespräch
mit unserem ARD Korrespondenten in Kiew
mit Darko jakowie wird
was ist denn da jetzt genau passiert
weiß man inzwischen mehr über diesen
Angriff dieser Explosion die wir gerade
in den Bildern noch mal gesehen haben
vor allem über die Hintergründe dieser
Sprengung
also auch heute abend herrscht
Unklarheit wer oder was eigentlich diese
Katastrophe ausgelöst hat was hat
eigentlich zu Zerstörung dieses Dammes
gefühlt es gibt natürlich sofort erst
einmal die Beschuldigung die
gegenseitigen also Russen und Ukrainer
beschuldigen sich gegenseitig diese
Sprengung verursacht zu haben und es
gibt aber inzwischen auch eine dritte
Mutmaßung dass es vielleicht auch sein
könnte dass dieser staudammt aus Sowjet
Zeiten handelt also er wurde in den 50er
Jahren gebaut das ist da viele viele
ältere Schäden gegeben haben soll und
dass der vielleicht auch in sich
zusammengebrochen sei das ist sozusagen
eine neue Mutmaßung aber es bleibt dabei
das beide Seiten sich gegenseitig
beschuldigen wenn dich ein großer Zufall
wenn dieser Damm ausgerechnet in dem
Moment bricht dann dort die der
ukrainische Angriff auf russische
Stellungen zu erwarten ist
Schuldzuweisung sie haben gesagt gab es
gibt es jetzt gegenseitig
interessant ist ja
dass beide Seiten betroffen sind
angeblich hat ist die russische Seite ja
schon vorher evakuiert worden also vor
allen Dingen es sind landwirtschaftliche
Flächen betroffen in der Ukraine im
Ukrainisch besetzten Teil auf der
anderen Seite aber auch die ist die
Trinkwasserversorgung für die
grimmgefährdet und auch dort das
Bewässerungssystem was sagt uns denn
dieser Sachverhalt beide haben sich egal
wer es jetzt war eigentlich dann ja
irgendwie auch selbst beschädigt
all das was Sie ansprechen das mag eine
Rolle spielen aber wir können es zur
Stunde tatsächlich nicht unabhängig
überprüfen also es wird sicherlich noch
einige Tage dauern bis wir die konkreten
Dinge die da ursächlich waren für dieses
heutige Ereignis erkennen können und
auch erst einmal auch das ganze Ausmaß
erst einmal verstehen können was ist da
eigentlich passiert sie sagten es es
sind beide Seiten des Flusses betroffen
und sind ja zuallererst einmal die
Menschen weil es sind Wassermassen die
da Fluss abwärts hinunter strömen
umkontrolliert Strömen und wir haben
sozusagen viele viele Ortschaften auf
der Ukrainisch kontrollierten Seite wo
Menschen evakuiert werden nur eine Zahl
heute hat Präsident selenski gesagt dass
16000 Menschen gleich evakuiert werden
müssen und bislang liegt uns bisher nur
eine offizielle Zahl vor von evakuierten
auf dem Ukrainisch kontrollierten teilen
das sind ca
.000.300 Menschen also sie merken da
sind noch viele viele zehntausende
Menschen und das nicht nur auf
ukrainischer Seite sondern eben auch auf
der russische Seite der besetzten Seite
die da evakuiert werden müssen und das
ganz ganz schnell es ist ein Wettlauf
gegen die Zeit was wird denn da jetzt
befürchtet ähm für die Menschen entlang
des Flusses
ja auch liegt was muss befürchtet werden
gibt es da auch eine Prognose
also es ist erst einmal so dass viele
viele Dörfer da überflutet worden sind
und ich kann mir im Augenblick nicht
vorstellen dass da auf nächster Zeit
überhaupt ein Leben mehr möglich ist
dass die Menschen dorthin zurückkehren
können das müssen wir noch einige Tage
abwarten um die genauen Schäden auch
erkennen zu können aber es gibt
natürlich auch noch eine andere Punkt
weiter nördlich des Staudammes da liegt
ja das AKW saporicia und heute morgen
gab es zunächst einmal eine ja
beruhigende Nachricht der ja aus Wien
das also es keine unmittelbare
Gefährdung gibt für das AKW saporicia
aber hier in der Ukraine da ist man sich
diese Sache noch nicht so ganz sicher
weil man hat gemerkt und sieht dass der
Wasserpegel dort beim AKW zurückgegangen
ist und man wird tatsächlich noch einige
Tage beobachten müssen was heißt das
eigentlich für die Reaktion die dort ja
gekühlt werden müssen mit dem Wasser und
wenn das nicht mehr aus reicht wenn das
aus bleibt dann könnte es tatsächlich
auch kritisch werden rund um das AKW
saporisch ja
soweit mein Kollege Darko und Jakow hier
wird schon zum live aus Kiefer zum Bruch
des der Staumauer von vielen Dank nach
Kiel
ja
kein hat dieser Krieg nicht nur die
Bilder die wir jetzt gerade gesehen
haben mit möglicherweise eine
militärischen Angriff auf eine ein
ziviles
Infrastrukturprojekt auf die Staumauer
dieser Krieg eine neue Dynamik erhalten
auch wenn man auf die letzten Tage schon
sieht jetzt gibt es auch Angriffe hinter
der russischen Front drohen haben es bis
kurz vor den Kreml geschafft
sollten da Truppen
kämpfen da auf eigene Rechnungen was ist
da los im Moment was du Dynamik angeht
also wir wissen ja nicht wie den wie für
die die Verantwortung für die sprengende
Staumauer aber es fühlt sich sozusagen
eine größeres Bild was wir so seid
Oktober November etwas sehen dass die
russische Seite darauf setzt die Ukraine
nennt sich zu einem fails die zu machen
also mit gezielten klingen auf die
zivilen vor Strukturen Energieversorgung
die Krankenhäuser die
Lebensmittelversorgung jetzt
möglicherweise ich drück mich ganz
vorsichtig auf auf einen stauraumauer
das fühlt sich in den größeres Bild das
losgelöst von den politischen Ambitionen
die man mit der Ukraine hat das
unterschwellige ziel ist die Ukraine
nennt sich ungewohnt zu machen und
migrationströme gehen kann zu setzen
natürlich auch umgekehrt sein dass
gerade diese Aktivitäten von den Markus
Keimen jetzt gerade schon gesprochen hat
dass Sie darauf hinweisen dass der Krimi
die Kontrolle zumindestens teilweise
über diesen Krieg verloren hat
was besonders auffällig ist ist
jedenfalls dass die russische Seite
nicht in der Lage ist die Grenzregionen
so Ukraine zu sichern Brians Kurs
Belgrad wo immer wieder ethnische Russen
zum Teil narzisstische ethische Russen
in mehreren Milizen einfallen und dort
Angst und Schrecken zu verbreiten und
den Bewohnern dort deutlich zu machen
dass der Staat sie nicht schützen kann
und was neben diesem Kontrollverlust in
den Grenzregionen auf russischer Seite
dazu kommt ist der Umstand dass das
Verteidigungsministerium in Moskau
offensichtlich nicht mehr die
Informationshoheit hat gestern meldet
man Erfolge gegen eine angebliche
ukrainische Offensive und kurz danach
widersprechen ein Kommandant in der
Regionen heute ihr gegen
Freiburg würden die aktuelle Lage in
Washington gesehen das ist ja der hat
nicht nur der hauptwaffenlieferant das
ist der wichtigste Beschützer der
Ukraine der Einsatz der USA und von Joe
Biden sind ja wesentlich damit
verantwortlich das Putin nicht
durchmarschiert ist und das ganze Land
platt machen konnte wie wird die
Entwicklung jetzt gerade in Washington
beurteilt wir haben sehr großer Sorge
denn auch wenn wir noch nicht genau
wissen was die Faktenlage vor Ort ist
sind doch die Auswirkungen eigentlich
die eines klassischen Hybriden Angriffs
wir haben es eben schon im Beitrag
gehört leiden wird die Zivilbevölkerung
leiden wird aber auch der Brotkorb
Ukraine das ist noch mal der einer der
wenigen Kontaktpunkte der noch existiert
zwischen Russland und der
internationalen Gemeinschaft nämlich mit
dem ausfuhrdeal des Weizens über den
Hafen und Dessert auch das wird jetzt
mittelfristig schwieriger große Felder
große Landstriche sind durch das
überschwemmte Kanalsystem vermutlich
nicht mehr zu retten auch für die
ukrainische Bevölkerung heißt das
natürlich einiges was
Ernährungssicherheit angeht wir haben
gehört wie schlecht die
evakuierungszahlen sind wie schleppend
das vorangeht und es verringert
natürlich jedenfalls auf Zeit die die
große Grenze zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine bzw die die die
eigentliche kampfeszone wird kleiner das
spielt den Russen in die Hände wenn sie
jetzt quasi eine Frühjahrsoffensive
erwarten oder die angekündigt war also
die Amerikaner beobachten all diese
Verunsicherungen und wirklich diese fast
systematischen Vorgehen gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung Herr Keim hat es
angesprochen natürlich mit ganz ganz
großer Sorge denn das sind hagerverträge
das sind alle Dinge die wir 1945 und im
Nachgang festgelegt haben im
internationalen Recht und Gesetz die da
einfach weiter abgerissen werden
systematisch und das Kriegs Völkerrecht
geht es da im Besonderen ist
möglicherweise jetzt der Moment für
Peking gekommen aktiv in den Krieg
einzugreifen und zwar als Vermittler
wegen hat sich schon immer als
Vermittler angeboten und seit gefühlten
drei Monaten gibt es so ein Konzept mit
dem China die den ganzen Ukraine Krieg
lösen und bzw den Frieden zurückbringen
möchte allerdings ähm ist ein bisschen
low profile also macht sich unbemerkbar
er ist seit einigen Wochen gibt es eine
gesamte für den Ukraine Krieg
der Weg den Peking ziemlich klar dass
man durch Gespräche nur durch Gespräche
diesen Krieg sofort beendet und Frieden
zurück in die Regierung bringt
schauen wir vielleicht noch mal auf
diese unglaublichen Bilder dieses Tages
hermanngott
viele Sicherheitspolitiker auch der
deutsche Bundeskanzler sind sicher es
waren die Russen die das diesen
Staumauer in Kauf in die in die Luft
gesprengt haben wem nützt das eigentlich
äh jetzt diese diese Sprengung dieser
oder eben dass diese dieser Stausee
sagen dass etwas neutraler jetzt
ausläuft wer hat davon mehr Russland
weil er damit die mögliche früher als ob
sogenannte früher als Offensive der
Ukrainer gehemmt wird oder gibt's da
noch andere Nutzen dieser oder auch
diejenigen die man damit besonders
schädigen kann
für mich hat schon erstaunt die
westliche Politiker von Stoltenberg bis
Scholz von Borell bis Michelle gemeint
haben Russland wäre für diese Tat
verantwortlich wir haben einfach derzeit
noch keine Belege dafür die würde ich
sagen muss es ist wahrscheinlicher dass
es ein russischer Anschlag war als er
ukrainischer für Russland bietet diese
diesen Bruch des Staudamms das eine
gestern schon in den telegram Kanälen
angekündigte amphibisch Operation der
ukrainischen Armee hin zum linken von
Russland kontrollierten Ufer des nibro
stattfinden kann denn das schwere Geräte
Ukraine kann in diesen jetzt
überfluteten und dann versuchten
Gebieten nicht mehr vorwärts kommen auf
der anderen Seite riskiert Russland die
Wasserversorgung für die Südosten von
Russland besetzten Regionen und für die
Creme der Vorteil allerdings ist stärker
weil wenn die Ukraine hier bei Personen
nicht auf das ostufe des Depot umsetzt
umsetzen kann dann man kann Russland de
facto die Frontlinie verkleinern entlang
der sich sich gegen mögliche Vorstöße
der ukrainischen Armee schützen muss für
ein ukrainische Täterschaft spricht dass
durch diese Überflutung auch die
russischen Verteidigungsstellungen am
Ostufer die minengürtel zerstört werden
gegen die ukrainische Täterschaft
spricht wie gesagt der Umstand dass die
Ukraine jetzt auf geraume Zeit zu einem
fibischen Operation und einem
militärischen Vorgehen am Ostufer nicht
mehr fähig sein wird inwieweit bedeutet
das eigentlich eine Einschränkung der
ukrainischen militärischen Fähigkeiten
wenn jetzt da keine Möglichkeit mehr
besteht da anzugreifen wir warten ja
sozusagen immer stündlich auf diese
offensichtliche die ursprünglich eine
früher als offensichtliche jetzt haben
wir eigentlich ja schon Sommer
hängt das die Möglichkeiten der Ukraine
jetzt entscheidend tatsächlich gegen
Russland in den besetzten Gebieten
russisch gesetzten vorzugehen was sie
eine Voraussetzung ist für
Friedensverhandlungen dass ich schwer zu
beurteilen sie sagen es ja selber wir
erwarten diese Frühjahrsoffensive seit
drei vier Monaten und gestern kam die
meldungswerte begonnen ich habe mich
gestern gefragt was sehen die
Kolleginnen aus den internationalen
Medien was ich noch nicht gesehen habe
und es ist sehr schwer zu unterscheiden
was sagen eine übliche Militäroperation
ist und wirklich der Beginn der
Frühjahrsoffensive sein soll weil wir
haben mit Truppenbewegungen ohnehin
alltäglich und wir reden über eine
Freund von bislang 1600 km das heißt
nicht jede truppenwiesen ist ein früher
so Offensive aber tatsächlich dass das
er gestern gesehen haben die ersten
Truppenbewegungen um doch jetzt herum
und zumindest die Vermutung oder ist
darum gehen könnte die Landbrücke zur
Grimmen abzutreffen deuten darauf hin
dass es zumindest eine überlegen gewesen
die Seite die ist ja auch öffentlich was
diskutiert worden und das wäre für
diesen Fall wirklich eine schweren ist
das Vorgehens
die USA sind ja wir sehen hier übrigens
die Karte noch einmal
Cherson die Stadt das ist die
Gebietshauptstadt Ukrainisch
kontrollierten Teil Nova kochovka das
ist der Ort wo die Staumauer ist und der
Stau damals ein sehr sehr langer Stausee
über 200 km lang das Atomkraftwerk von
saporizona liegt ja auch in den
mittleren Teil ist davon ja auch
betroffen braucht dass das Kühlwasser
gleichzeitig geht südlich noch eine ein
Kanal ab bei novakarovka Richtung Grimm
das ist die staffierte Halbinsel ganz
unten mit der Trinkwasserversorgung und
auch mit der Versorgung
landwirtschaftlicher
Bewässerungssysteme die USA sind ja
immer genau informiert überall das was
in den äh in der Ukraine passiert durch
eine ausgefallen ist Satellitentechnik
sie liefern ja auch die Information an
die Ukraine in Washington ist auch noch
keine Offensive bemerkt worden es gibt
nicht also Geheimdienst Informationen
werden und sowieso nicht offensichtlich
mitgeteilt was wir natürlich wissen ist
dass wir in der Ukraine gerade eine
unglaubliche Umtriebigkeit besonders
amerikanischer Unternehmen haben die
genau solche Bilder zur Verfügung
stellen von Elon Musk staling bis hin zu
den Kollegen in Anführungszeichen von
pallant hier die natürlich auf
unterschiedliche Art und Weise genau
solches Wissen an die amerikanischen
Geheimdienste herantragen was ist aber
sehr wohl getan hat also auch ohne diese
eine öffentliche eine öffentliche
Zuschlag es hat den Ton verschärft es
hat Kommentare gegeben wieder von
Anthony Blinken der dir derzeit wieder
auf Europa Tournee unterwegs war wenn
man so möchte noch mal viel mit
Alliierten gesprochen hat und
Verbündeten und der noch mal betont hat
es ginge jetzt als Kriegsziel wirklich
darum alle besetzten Gebiete der Ukraine
zu befreien und die Amerikaner haben
sich strategisch in den letzten Monaten
natürlich immer so positioniert dass sie
sich ein bisschen intern die Bälle
zugespielt haben was sei denn nun das
Kriegsziel das war natürlich auch immer
das wird das schwierige innerhalb der
westlichen Koalition zumindest jetzt
noch bleiben was können wir eigentlich
der der Ukraine als Kriegsziel empfehlen
und was wollen wir unterstützen aber
angesichts dieser Bilder und Angesicht
dessen der der Konsequenzen die da noch
kommen hat Toni blinken in den letzten
Tagen noch mal unter gestern noch mal
deutlich seinen Thun verschärft
denn die asiatischen Verbündeten von
Putin Indien besonders china hält man
das für eine besondere Nervosität
Moskaus möglicherweise die
Kurzschlussreaktion der Mango hat gesagt
möglicherweise wurden da Informationen
bekannt dass unmittelbar eine
amphibische Aktivität also ein Angriff
über den tierprovorstand von
ukrainischer Seite wie sieht man die
auch die Psychologie oder die die
Stabilität dieses Verbündeten Russland
von Seiten seiner Verbündeten den Asien
ähm offiziell wir sind eigentlich so
viel wie viel Einfluss China auf auf
Entscheidung hat klar
gesprächskanal zwischen immer wieder
ausgetauscht wird Chinas
produktionsklage china möchte kein
Atomkrieg auf irgendein europäischen
Kontinent haben das hat der China
Staatspräsidentin beim Treffen die
Staatspräsident Putin auch schon
ziemlich klar gesagt also keine
Atomwaffen also keine Einsatz von
Atomwaffen und was den Krieg angeht ist
China immer dafür hinterher
verschossenen Türen die Fäden
zusammenzuziehen weil man kann ja alle
alle alle offene Fragen auf der Tisch
hauen und dann sind alle Beteiligten
können sich nicht einigen und das bringt
ja nichts machen ja
stierschweigende Diplomatie hinter
verschlossenen Türen und der Sonne
Botschafter hat schon eine Rundreise
durch Europa gemacht war unter anderem
auch in Deutschland in Deutschland
Berlin und hat ihn davon fest überzeugt
dass die konkrete Pläne auf den Tisch
gelegt haben auch nach abstimmen muss
versuchen man so einen großen
großmöglichen Nenner zu finden um
überhaupt was Substanzielles auf die
wahre Schale zu werfen damit man
überhaupt Gemeinsamkeiten im Moment sind
so wie sie sind und ziemlich
konfrontativ und
da muss man irgendwie ihr mal her und
kann mir vorstellen deswegen gern die
Rolle übernehmen möchte mein Gott jetzt
wissen wir ja dass Russland in der
Ukraine seit dem Überfall im Februar
2022 unglaublich viel zivile
Infrastruktur auch zerstört hat
es gibt ja die Möglichkeit dann noch
viel mehr zu zerstören dass
Atomkraftwerk in saporicia ist ja sehr
gefährdet wenn das Massiv militärisch
attackiert wird das wirklicherweise
Radioaktivität frei setzen die weit über
die Ukraine hinaus dann zu spüren wird
sein wird bzw die Strahlung es wird ja
immer über allem so besprochen also die
letzte Konsequenz wäre möglicherweise
das Putin eine erfolgreichen Angriff auf
die Krim durch die Ukraine betaktischen
Atomwaffen verhindern möchte
besteht diese Gefahr noch wenn diese
anderen ja eskalationsmöglichkeiten
Infrastruktur zerstören Cyberware wenn
die Versagen das Putin dann zum letzten
Mittel greift
ich denke schon leider denn ein Verlust
der Krim würde sehr wahrscheinlich mit
dem Sturz von Wladimir Putin einhergehen
das heißt Putin kann es sich nicht
leisten die Creme zu verlieren und wenn
dieses Risiko einer Einnahme da kriegen
durch die ukrainischen Truppen besteht
dann halte ich den Einsatz von
taktischen Nuklearwaffen zwar nicht für
wahrscheinlich aber für möglich für ein
Restrisiko dass man im Westen
kalkulieren muss auf dass man
vorbereitet sein muss und deswegen ist
es auch ungemein wichtig dass man im
Westen klärt und eine einheitliche
Meinung gibt es dazu nicht wozu man denn
die Ukraine mit den Waffenlieferungen
befähigen möchte was sie militärische
reichen soll etwa die Zurückdrängung der
russischen Truppen auf die Frontlinie
von 23 februar oder aber doch die
Vertreibung einer Russen aus der Ukraine
das heißt auch von der Krim die Drohung
die Moskau schon wiederholt ausgestoßen
hat nämlich noch lehrerwaffen einsetzen
zu können nicht explizit aber implizit
ist das gesagt worden die wird von den
befürworten der Ukraine und in der
Ukraine zurückgewiesen man sagt es ist
ein blöfer Putin wolle damit nur Angst
und Unsicherheit in der westlichen
Bevölkerung führen und ja wir dürfen uns
nicht selber abschrecken lassen so die
Argumentation aber ich persönlich würde
meinen es ist ein Restrisiko da und die
Katastrophen Konsequenzen eines solchen
nuklearwaffeneinsatzes sind eben
solche dass man es auf einen Bluff nicht
ankommen lassen sollte für diese ist
dieser nukleare Einsatz dieser mögliche
immer noch auf der westlichen Agenda als
eine Möglichkeit oder glaubt man auch
eher an sagt er macht es dann doch nicht
letztendlich schadet er sich ja selbst
dann und ich glaube es setzt sich in der
westlichen Koalition besonders bei den
Amerikanern zunehmend genau dieser Punkt
durch nämlich die Tatsache dass das
absolute Signal der der kompletten
Schwäche und im Grunde genommen das
kompletten Kontrollverlust dieses
Krieges von Wladimir Putin wäre oder
seitens bleibt mir potenzielle denn dann
würde ihm der Kollege hatte schon
angesprochen die unterstütz der Chinesen
wegbrechen das braucht er händeringend
um seine Wirtschaft zu Hause aufrecht zu
erhalten die Sanktionen haben ihnen in
der Tat schon ziemlich in die Knie
gezwungen dass wir dann nur noch 0,3%
Wirtschaftswachstum hatten aber der
Internationale Währungsfonds sieht mit
der Hilfe Chinas mit den Aufkäufen
fossiler Energie Indiens mit der
Koalition der sogenannten bricks die
sich ja ziemlich praktisch jedenfalls
wirtschaftlich um Russland geschart
haben ein Wirtschaftswachstum jetzt für
Russland im nächsten Jahr also warum
würde er und wir reden mal gar nicht von
dem nuklearen Fallout also einerseits
ist genau Wasser ist die eine Konsequenz
eine Sprengung eines Damms aber wenn
eine ein ein nuklear Angriff gibt dann
sind natürlich auch die russischen
Soldaten getroffen dann sind die
Grenzregionen betroffen dann noch quasi
zu Hause ein Land zusammenzuhalten das
wird natürlich immer schwieriger also
insofern ist das von den wird vom Westen
das die Nutzung einer Nuklearwaffe als
absolutes Bekenntnis der absoluten
Grunde genommen das Kriegsverlust von
Wladimir Putin
was wir wissen und ich finde die
amerikanischen Geheimdienste dieser
lassen der interessante Dinge
durchsickern hat ja auch die Regierung
Bayern schon kommuniziert das wäre nicht
der Kasus Beni aber dann würden Sie
sagen Waffen liefern die Wahrheit auf
russisches Territorium reichen würden
und würden die Ukraine auch nicht mehr
zügeln diese einzusetzen also es wäre
eine konventionelle Reaktion die du
Russen sehr schwächen würde aber ich bin
umgekehrt genau wie sie angedeutet haben
man muss ja gar nicht mit der nuklear
aber vertrauen oder Atomkraftwerk hat
was man sozusagen
[Musik]
Landstriche vernichtet die
Lebensgrundlage der Menschen die dort
sind
Elend Armut für diese Menschen die keine
Möglichkeit wenn sie gerade noch
entkommen sind kein Zuhause mehr haben
möglicherweise wenn landwirtschaftliche
die betroffen ist sogar
Hunger in großem Ausmaß und zwar nicht
nur in der Ukraine sondern auch in den
Ländern die auf ukrainisches Getreide
angewiesen sind das sind viele Länder in
Afrika damit kann man ja auch sehr viel
anstellen das würde natürlich ins Bild
passen denn selbst in der Verlängerung
des getreideabkommens hat Russland und
noch mal das ist quasi der einzige Punkt
in dem Diplomatie noch existiert indem
man Austausch noch existiert außer beim
Gefangenen Austausch und selbst da hat
Russland ja in Anführungszeichen schon
dreckige Spielchen gespielt nur um 30
Tage zu verlängern vielleicht um 60 dann
die Umsetzung zu verschleppen und und
und und und und und das würde also uns
Spiel passen noch mal das sind sehr
komplexe Kanalsysteme die genau die
Felder bewässern um die es jetzt geht
und das passt genau und die Definition
der hybriden Kriegsführung die wir
eigentlich von vorne rein von Wladimir
Putin erwartet haben zusätzlich
gepartner natürlich mit Cyber Anschlägen
aber diese sind zumindest im großen Maße
jedenfalls von der westlichen
Infrastruktur und einer langen
vorbereitenden Struktur die seit 2014 im
Raum steht verhindert worden also er
wird schauen welche Hybriden ja quasi
Werkzeuge stehen eben noch zur Verfügung
und das spricht meiner Meinung nach
schon dafür dass es eigentlich ein
russischer Angriff sein muss
mein Gott es finden jetzt in der ab der
nächsten Woche gleichzeitig Manöver im
Ostseeraum statt und zwar sowohl von der
NATO eher Defender die größte
luftwaffenübung seit der Gründung des
nordatlantikpaktes 1949 und ein paar
Kilometer war der im Osten gibt's
Manöver der Russen das heißt man muss
jetzt sich gar nicht mehr bei wie das
bei einem Manöver Szenario so üblich ist
sich den Feind virtuell vorstellen der
ist quasi ums Eck wartet schon in
Sichtweite ist das eine gefährliche
Situation die da in dieser Woche und in
der nächsten Woche entstehen wird bei
diesem
parallelverlaufenden Manövern dass sie
parallel verlaufen ist ja kein Zufall
nun es gibt schon das Risiko einer
Fehlkalkulation einer
missverständlichen Interpretation
gegenreischer Züge in diesen Manövern
aber ich glaube beide Seiten werden
alles tun dass es hier nicht so eine
Zwischenfall kommt dann wird es die NATO
dran interessiert in den direkten
Konflikt mit Russland zu geraten noch
will Russland einen direkten
militärischen Konflikt mit der NATO es
ist beunruhigend das ist denkmöglich
dass etwas passieren könnte aber nicht
eben wahrscheinlich
welche Erkenntnisse könnten die Chinesen
aus diesem Manöver der NATO in der
Ostsee ziehen denn vor der Haustür
Chinas gibt es ja auch einen gewaltigen
konfliktwert mit Taiwan massiver
truppenprinzessin sowohl der Chinesen
als auch der der USA glauben die
Chinesen vielleicht das da schon ein
bisschen was geprobt wird was auch in
der Straße von Formosa eines Tages
interessant oder virulent werden könnte
ihre eigenen
keine Gewässer da gab es in Wochenende
Zwischenfall wo du nicht chinesische
Fregatte amerikanischen Kriegsschiff in
über den Weg gelaufen war
das sind es ist Einzelmeldungen die die
ganze Welt verunruhigt aber
langfristige meine ganze Periode die
letzten Jahrzehnte zurückblickt
passieren solche Zwischenfälle ziemlich
oft und die sind eigentlich geübt hier
und die die Soldaten sind eigentlich
dafür da um zu provozieren
zu reagieren das ist eigentlich an sich
wenn man das wird anschaut ist sehr
spektakulär aber das ist ähm die
Business ja das ist den ähm Tina
betrachtet teilbares eine abtrünnige
Provinz und dass die Amerikaner mit viel
viel Militär da sind sind Gefäß Peking
nicht und die sind eigentlich trainiert
da hier auf diese diesen Zwischenfall zu
zu reagieren aber gleichzeitig gibt es
auch eine gewisse vor dem Philippinen
auch eine gemeinsame Übung mit den USA
mit China mit Australien geht aber
wirklich um
anitären äh Hilfe im im Falle eine
Katastrophe also von daher die Übung
sind gut wenn man sich gegenseitig
versteht und viel Kalkulation zu
vermeiden das sind insofern gut also
auch hierhin in der Ostsee oder wenn
wenn die NATO gleichzeitig geübt Russen
dann guckt man sich gegenüber der
Schulter was macht ihr wie machen wir
wenn man weiß was die anderen tun singt
das glaube ich zumindest das Risiko eine
viel Kalkulation
mein Gott wenn wir auf die Kriegsführung
der Russen sehen dann fällt auch etwas
besonders auf dass der Krieg jedenfalls
an den neuralgischen Punkten gar nicht
von der regulären Armee geführt wird
sondern von der sogenannten
Söldnergruppe Wagner
die ja offensichtlich da auch der
Aktivposten auf der militärischen Seite
der Russen sind man hat den Eindruck
dass diese Gruppe eigentlich das
militärische Geschehen auf russischer
Seite dominiert ist diese Gruppe Wagen
ist das eine
Eliteeinheit werden
die Truppen des
Verteidigungsministeriums die regulären
russischen Truppen eher so Staffagen in
diesem konfliktieren müssen wir das
verstehen weil es doch etwas
Ungewöhnliches ist
die Gruppe Wagner die ihr seit 2013 gibt
die besteht oder bestand damals und
lange Jahre danach vor allem aus
ehemaligen Soldaten der russischen
armeefallen von Spezialeinheiten also
das waren wirklich gut ausgebildete gut
trainierte gut ausgerüstete Soldaten
aber auch Wagner hat viele davon in den
bisherigen kämpfen schon verloren heute
ist Wagner eben nicht nur eine
militärische liedeinheit sondern sie hat
auch zum Teil noch weniger ausgerüstete
wenig ausgebildete und trainierte
Soldaten die jetzt in ihren reinkämpfen
dass sie aber militärisch erfolgreich
sein kann in den meisten Fällen ist auf
der Grund warum dies worum es diese
Gruppe noch gibt den politisch gesehen
ist das was ich gegen der Begründer
dieser Gruppe
zeigt nämlich ständig den
Verteidigungsminister gerade
im Hof zu kritisieren etwas was Putin
sich eigentlich nicht gefallen lassen
könnte und es gab sogar eine Äußerung
brigologischen nämlich eine alte Oper in
Moskau eben vielleicht auch unrecht
haben könnte dass die Ziele in der
Ukraine erreicht werden können und alle
wissen dass in der russischen Opposition
tut ihn immer als Opa bezeichnet wird
oder als bunkeroper also das heißt dass
er indirekt auch schon gegen Putin
vorgegangen ist ob er pregorian da noch
weitergehen kann oder ob sein
ablebensrisiko damit steigt das werden
die nächsten Wochen zeigen er fällt
damit ja auch dem russischen Generalstab
irgendwie in den Rücken man hatte das
Gefühl da Wedel der Schwanz mit dem Hund
auf russischer Seite wie ist dieses ist
das sind das sind das viele
Einschätzungen das Wirklichkeit begossen
da den Ton angibt oder ist das eine
Taktik mit der man den Gegner vielleicht
sogar verwirren will in die Irre führen
will es gibt ja noch einen anderen Krieg
Herren der damit spielt kadirus aus
Tschetschenien steht in Brutalität
und seiner Gruppe in nichts nach wie ist
diese auch Hybride Kriegsführung jetzt
zu verstehen was will Putin damit
erreichen oder hat er vielleicht das
Heft des Handeln sogar schon etwas aus
der Hand geben müssen also so was wir
feststellen ist eine Dezentralisierung
der russischen Kriegsführung es ist ja
genauso wie sie sagen für deutsche oder
westliche Verhältnisse sehr ungewöhnlich
dass noch neben organisierten
etablierten legitimiert mit ihr noch
eine weitere Einheit die das kennen wir
aus Deutschland so ähnlich oder aus den
USA so ähnlich zumindest nicht bei
außerhalb setzen man kann verschiedene
Theorien Vorbringen ich würde wäre so
ein bisschen zurückhaltend zu glauben
dass die Macht von Präsident
erodiert und dass sie dass sie jetzt
Anzeichen eines Systemwechsel sind gegen
Theorie wäre das Präsent Putin das auch
im Moment erstmal laufen lässt und
gucken wie sich mit pregorientieren also
wir aus der Position
mutig genug ist den Kopf hinauszustecken
und dann von Präsidentin gegebenenfalls
in wenigen Wochen einfach auf der Kopf
drauf zu bekommen also in einer Form
sagte mir koordiniert bedroht oder sogar
getötet zu werden das werden müssen
wir kennen das aus Deutschland nicht
aber aus den USA sehr wohl diese
privaten Militärfirmen die gibt es sie
waren im Irak in Einsatz sie waren in
Afghanistan im Einsatz also da würde ich
widersprechen wollen meinen Kollegen
kein ja das heißt die USA wie sehen sie
auf diese
Kriegsführung wie gesagt mit eigenen
Erfahrungen Mangos hat gerade gesagt
nein Osten ist das sozusagen auch für
die USA eine völlig normale mit
militärische Aktivität die dann die
Gruppe Wagner an den Tag zumindest keine
neue Aktivität der Russen jetzt kommt
interessanterweise kommen jetzt
Einheiten dazu die russische
Privatunternehmen stellen das finde ich
eine fast noch merkwürdigere Entwicklung
die dann rekrutieren auf der Basis von
zukünftigen Bezahlungen und
unternehmensrollen die die ich sehr
merkwürdige finde umgekehrt ist noch
wichtiger vielleicht noch mal die
wagnergruppe als global agierende Gruppe
zu verstehen und das ist natürlich den
Amerikanern weiterhin ein großes Dorn im
Auge denn die wagnergruppe hat im Grunde
genommen ihren Namen gemacht indem sie
für Russland besonders in Afrika aktiv
war sich bezahlen hat mit minenrechten
also all die Dinge die die Amerikaner
jetzt in den Gesprächen mit den
Europäern quasi wieder gerade rücken
wollen nämlich wie kommen wir in Zukunft
an kritische Bodenmaterialien wie kommen
wir an die Dinge die unsere
Wirtschaftsräume beide voranbringen da
haben der hat die wagnergruppe in
Anführungszeichen in Afrika schon große
Teile des Aufzug mit unter
aufzuteilenden
Rohmaterial Kuchen für sich eingenommen
auf der Basis natürlich von autoritären
autoritären Taktiken und so weiter und
so fort also das auf einmal Länder dann
in anderen Teilen wiederum organisierten
Banden Gruppen dieser Art ähm
gegenüberstehen das sind natürlich
Ausprägungen der sich verschiebenden
gleichgewichtsströme in der
internationalen Politik schon fast 400
Jahre her dass ein Bekannter den
ATZ beträgt hat dass der Krieg den Krieg
ernährt das war Wallenstein 30 jährigen
Krieg erinnert so ein bisschen an diese
Sache das ist ein Riesengeschäft ist
sehen wir zu sehen noch auf militärische
Aspekte ist der wirtschaftlich Aspekte
ökonomisch Aspekt von Kriegsführung bei
uns nicht so richtig auf dem Radarschirm
nein ich würde mich eher helfen
anschließen wollen tatsächlich kommt
immer etwas hinzu das Wagner auch
erlaubt sozusagen verdeckt Operationen
zu führen also Operation die im Auftrag
im Namen mir im Auftrag als im Namen der
russischen Führung durchgeführt werden
in Syrien in malen in der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik Libyen
oder anderen Ort die sagen erlauben der
russischen Regierung zu sagen da haben
wir gar nichts mehr zu tun und das ist
ja auch lange ihre Politik gewesen zu
sein das ist ein völlig autonome Einheit
die da steht in unserem Befehl
austrinken sich doch der Eindruck auf
dass sie zu weniger im Namen handelt
aber beim Auftragen und damit ist sie
ein wirksames Instrument russischer
Geopolitik gewesen und dass er
eigentlich noch vor dem Ukraine Konflikt
seit 2011 in Libyen Präsident seit 2015
in Syrien also die Entwicklung seit 10
Jahren aber Möglichkeit würde ich nur
noch mal darauf hinweisen dass wir
Bodenschätze in der Ostukraine haben da
dreht sich um 12,3 Trillionen Dollar
wenn man das alles quasi zu Tage führen
würde und das dürfen wir auch nicht
vergessen also dass da Kalkulationen mit
schwingen besonders einer einer
autoritären macht die versucht quasi
noch das weiß ich zu halten was sie kann
wirtschaftlich und demografisch das wird
irgendwo mit schwingen im Kalkül eines
Vladimir Putin im Grammel wir reden also
über Eskalation des Krieges immer mehr
Eskalation in diesem Krieg auch mit
immer weitreichenden Folgen auch ja
geopolitische Art dass möglicherweise
sich die westlichen Staaten eines Tages
gezwungen fühlen der Ukraine tatsächlich
neben dem kampfschutz auch weitreichende
Artillerie und Raketenwaffen zu liefern
die auch Russland erreichen können um
den Krieg irgendwann mal zu beenden das
wiederum könnte den die die
Eskalationsspirale weiter nach oben
treiben
UI ist den vorstellbar und USA als die
eigentlichen Weltpolizisten im Moment
sich eines Tages zusammentun und das
Treiben von jeweils von ihrer Seite
beenden in der treibt nicht also den
Krieg in der Ukraine Beenden
der Polizeistation haben sie ja schon
verschiedene Ländern ja sagen sie nach
amtlichen Angaben sind das eigentlich
die Selbsthilfegruppe von einem
bestimmten Menschen auf einem Landkreis
also zurück zum Thema Kran und China
wird diesen Krieg so schnell wie möglich
beenden und zwar aus eigenen Interesse
entschieden hat großes Interesse mit
europaweite und Wirtschaft zu betreiben
und mit so einem Europa das jetzt ein
verschrecken hier geraten ist schlecht
fürs Geschäft und die Chinesen bzw die
Regierung da ist ziemlich praktisch ob
China sich mit den USA zusammen tun wird
muss gewagt der These würde ich nicht
ausschließen wenn sie gemeinsam haben
zum Beispiel dass sie wirklich beide
sag mir Großmächte schulteren Schulter
was gemeinsam erreichen kann
wäre was sensationelles aber da sehe ich
im Moment nicht kommen zum Beispiel die
ran Saudi-Arabien vermittelt was was die
USA in der vergangen Jahrzehnte versucht
hatten und ohne Erfolg aber China hat es
geschafft
ich denke schon dass China an die
eigenen Kommunikationskanal orientieren
dass ich wirklich in getan zusammen tun
würde dann verliert man vielleicht die
Gesprächskanäle zu denen man konnte
daraus kommt ja sofort an die nächste
Frage wenn sich die Welt neu sortiert im
Moment wie sortiert sie sich denn neu
nun es ist vor allem der Westen der
lange Zeit versucht hat und nach dem
Motto gelebt hat Sicherheit mit Russland
und ohne Russland gibt es keine
Sicherheit auf dem europäischen
Kontinent hier gibt es doch einen
starken Paradigmenwechsel jetzt ist
eigentlich Konsens der dass man Schutz
vor Russland braucht vor einem
aggressiven revisionistischen
Russland das ist meine Sache das nach
schonend sehr starker Paradigmenwechsel
und das wird auch dazu führen dass die
NATO und die europäischen
Mitgliedstaaten der NATO Ihren Auftrag
ernst nehmen müssen nämlich mehr in die
Rüstung in die Verteidigungsfähigkeit zu
investieren denn es hatte dieser Krieg
einmal mehr gezeigt die Europäer sind
nicht in der Lage vielleicht nicht
einmal alle Willen sich selbst zu
verteidigen und es hat wieder der USA
bedürft der militärischen und der
politischen Führung um hier auf der
Seite der Ukraine gegen die Invasion zu
kämpfen also da ist Europa gefragt man
wird sehen ob die Bekenntnisse die es
von vielen Regierungen jetzt gegeben hat
wieder in die Verteidigung zu stecken
danach wahr gemacht werden denn im
Augenblick sind es nur acht von 31
Mitgliedsstaaten der NATO die dieses
2014 eingerichtete zwei Prozent Ziel
tatsächlich erreichen und übersteigen
acht von 31
das wird der Punkt des Nato-Gipfels Ende
Juni sein Herr Scholz stoltenberger
schon angekündigt er möchte deutlich auf
den Tisch schlagen so kann es nicht
weitergehen vor allen Dingen kann es
natürlich in der Zeit nicht so
weitergehen denn diese Verschleppung
quasi der anschaffungspolitik die wir
überall sehen wie Sie sehen wir in
Deutschland aber in Europa ganz
besonders im europäischen Arm der NATO
es muss sehr sehr viel möglicher möglich
sein Inter operabel in Waffensystemen zu
arbeiten aber viel interessanter noch
ist das was ich quasi hinter der
kriegslinie Tot nämlich eine neue
Alliierten Findung die bricks die
Brasilien Russland Indien China und
südamera Südafrika stärken sich an auf
neue Art und Weise den Rücken
militärisch ökonomisch eine Abkehr vom
doll System die jetzt sehr sehr
beschleunigt wird da entstehen neue
Koalitionen von denen der hybristische
Westen immer dachte alliierte und
Partner wirkliche Verbündete das können
nur wir nix also diese Links
Russland China Südafrika Brasilien und
Indien Bezug jetzt auf das was Sie
gesagt haben hat unser
Bundesverteidigungsminister da heute
eine Blutgrätsche gemacht in Delhi er
hat nämlich es dort zu Besuch und hat ja
hier Indien quasi es auf Werbetour
Umwelt Indien und sagt also wir nehmen
nicht alles auf die Goldwaage was ihr so
sagt auch so Richtung Russland in den
ist ja stark abhängig von
Waffenlieferungen aus Russland sondern
wir sind bereit über unseren Schatten zu
springen und ganz pragmatisch zu agieren
und diesen Ort und den hören wir uns mal
an heute morgen in
ich glaube wir sollten aufhören oder
anders gesagt wir sind gut beraten nicht
von jedem Bekenntnisse zu diesem und
jedem zu erwarten es ist völlig
eindeutig indien ist ein Partner und uns
sehr ähnlich in vielen wichtigen Fragen
ist eine ist eine größte Demokratie auf
der Welt wir sollten glaube ich nicht
darauf bestehen dass jetzt jeder diesen
russischen Angriffskrieg verurteilt alle
die meisten tun das indien hat eine
besondere Beziehung ist sehr abhängig
von russischen Rüstungsindustrie
Lieferung der vergangenen Jahre ich
glaube viel wichtiger ist nicht
wichtiger als die Frage der Bekenntnisse
ist die Frage des Verhalten von da ist
Indien sehr eindeutig ja super praktisch
erinnert an eine Äußerung des
chinesischen Spitzenpolitiker früherer
Jahre denkt sie okay der gesagt hat eine
ganz egal ob eine Katze Schwarz oder
Weiß ist Hauptsache Mäuse sind wir jetzt
auf Mäuse fahren
zumindest sehen wir in konkreto die
veränderten Rahmenbedingungen deutsche
aus und Sicherheitspolitik wir stellen
fest dass wir einmal geopolitisierten
Welt leben oder einer geopolitisiert
daran Welt leben wo tatsächlich die
Instrumente Deutschland europäischer
Politik der letzten Jahre sowas wie
menschenrechtsdialoge
justizstaatsdialog und anders und
interessant geworden sind jetzt geht es
darum bestimmte Akteure auf die eigene
Seite zu ziehen damit sie nicht auf die
andere Seite fahren und ich finde den
interessant passt was dir doch die nicht
auf der verteilungsminister hat ja auch
eine Lockerung der rüstungsexpertin aus
sich gestellt genau in diese Richtung
diese quälenden die warten um
Ersatzteile liegen geliefert werden
sollten sondern letztendlich abgelöst
werden von einer strategischen
Perspektive
Chinesen und in dass sie nicht die
allerbesten Freundin Asien ja man kann
die nicht einfach auf die Firma
reduzieren der Feind weil das Feindes
ist mein Freund oder meine Freundin
meine Freundin man sieht ja man ist ganz
pragmatisch also China den zwischen
Angriffskrieg nicht verurteilt hat
sondern hier den Zeigefinger erhoben
aber wo wir jetzt wenn es jetzt um eine
Xbox one deutsche U-Boote geht dann ist
man wieder ganz pragmatisch muss man
natürlich ich denkwürdig finde ich mein
Gott wir sind gleich am Ende der Sendung
vielleicht bitte auch noch eine kurze
Antwort ihr Leben ja möglicherweise
erleben wir eine Entwicklung hin zu
einer multipolaren Welt kann das auch
ein Vorteil sein wenn die Macht auf
mehrere Schultern verteilt ist dass man
sich so gegenseitig neutralisiert und
damit Konflikte vermeidet
und die Geschichte ist da nicht
eindeutig im 19 Jahrhundert hatten wir
in Europa eine Multi multipolare
Struktur das hat lange den Frieden
gehalten aber dann hat dieselbe Struktur
1914 diesen ersten Weltkrieg verursacht
multipolares System in neigen eher dazu
kompliziert zu sein es müssen mehrere
Akteure eingeschätzt werden sie können
auch viel eingeschätzt werden und ich
denke wir sind nicht in einem
multipolaransystem und ich erwarte eher
dass wenn dieser unipolare Moment der
USA dann endgültig vorbei sein wird dass
wir es mit einem bipolaren System aus
den USA und Indien aus und China zu tun
haben werden gut ähm verschiedene
Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten von uns auch
aufmerksam beobachtet ich bedanke mich
bei Katrin drüber Eisprung bei Markus
Keim bei ikea hat mein Gott zugeschaltet
aus Innsbruck Liebe Zuschauerinnen und
liebe Zuschauer morgen in der Phönix
Runde AFD im Umfrage hoch woher kommt
der Zuspruch aktuell ist bei Phoenix der
Tag mit Thomas Bade darin weitere
Reaktionen zur Zerstörung des Staudamms
von Kaufhof bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]